no rejects
hello reject bill I'm Greg I'm John so
we're gonna continue our weekend of
horror of the month of October on the
real rejects channel and we wanted to
also include one of our other new
segments called how it could work how it
could work is as a segue I came up with
where we'll take remakes and reboots
sequel ideas things that have been
talked about or recently announced or
potential crossovers pitch our idea or
how we think those films could work
here's how this could be cool and we
thought for a week in a horror we would
go with one of the remakes that's been
announced in the past few months and
that is the American Psycho reboot oh
boy how it could work do we know do we
know what their idea is right now let me
do the check that we said we were gonna
do what choke babies everybody you don't
do it I was gonna say here's how it
could work you don't do it oh yeah you
[ __ ] it up
go back nope too late now I don't
believe in retakes no I don't know what
their idea is they don't have any
specific ideas what I was telling John
before we filmed this video was I feel
that if anything if they do a remake of
American Psycho it should be sort of in
the vein of how they like remade
Scarface not like you know you can make
it about a gangster how the original
Scarface movie was about a very specific
gangster in a very specific time and it
was a different movie but it had the
same kind of structure of the rise and
fall of a gangster I feel with American
Psycho that they shouldn't do Patrick
Bateman again you just can't do that
there's the one guy who can do that and
as Christian Bale it's already been done
let it be I don't think anyone would be
on board for it but then John actually
came up with an idea and that I like
John's idea of what he actually came up
with I mean well the thing about
remaking American Psycho for me is I I
feel like the stuff that's potent
actually are the themes it's not like
Point Break where I'm like
I don't see the point unless you have
those people yeah if you do a different
guy and you just take the same themes of
what capitalism means to us now
immaterial I mean materialism means to
us now and and the sort of disconnect I
think you can make something really cool
so my idea would be to basically make it
about a Martin shkreli type now and if
you don't know who Martin shkreli is
just just google who Martin shkreli
isn't gonna find a million results but
in a nutshell he's he's you know a big
pharmaceutical business entrepreneur
he's kind of known for being a life
troll essentially and that's who I would
want to set an American Psycho story
around if it was me doing it this guy
who's clearly made enough success for
himself that he doesn't have to give a
[ __ ] about anybody Marsh Crowley I was
looking him up he had a pharmaceutical
company and there was these pills these
like really strong medication used to
treat cancer patients and they they were
about they averaged about a dollar fifty
dollar seventy-five per pill he spiked
at about 5,000 percent it was about $750
per pill beyond like just knowing that
one fact it's his interactions that I
saw him doing his interviews and him in
front of Congress that really kind of
shocked me the most was he's in front of
Congress [ __ ] ton of people like the
good whole room is packed he's like
considered the most hated man in America
at this moment any question he was
asking we just plead the fifth he's just
believed in any one increase saying it
is like slimy yeah slimy narcissistic he
just cast it he would mock them he will
able laugh at them and smile when and
when he really shouldn't have been he
was kind of like holy an evil mirror up
to their face in a lot of ways yeah yeah
there's who's a blatant disrespect there
for one reason or another
yeah and he's an interesting guy because
a lot of people like him like he has a
[ __ ] ton of Twitter followers well cuz
he's interesting to watch after watching
interviews and he is kind of a good next
step of a Patrick Bateman okay like
let's just ashy Patrick Bateman this for
a while Patrick Bateman you know you've
worked on Wall Street he was very much
image-obsessed it was all about
satisfying a certain image and oh yeah
it's all about your appearance and envy
of the appearance of your success and
what's on the outside and then my new
and then he would kill for you know his
thrills he was an empty guy and he would
kill to get his kicks
what makes Martin shkreli so different
is that he is also young like he's not
like Patrick Bateman was a fairly young
character and this guy is also young but
he's not he doesn't come across in the
same way where Patrick Bateman really
cared about what people thought about
him he really cared about his image this
guy Martin shkreli liked to base it off
a type like him would be really
interesting because his status is much
more public he's much more popular
Patrick Bateman was this guy who was
kind of always going trying to get
higher and there are people who he felt
were really above him and he hated that
this guy believes he is number one
Patrick Bateman is the reflection of
that kind of guy and and and that's fine
in our yeah in our society in that time
and I feel like martin shkreli's a guy
who is a good dark mirror for now
because you have that added level of
attention and narcissism because of
social media and because of the news and
whatnot but he's not he's a master
manipulator
yeah it seems like he's a master
manipulator and he got fired from his
company but he's still like has so much
money he's not someone who will ever say
he did anything wrong
he's not like Trump in the sense where
Trump you know you say something to him
he just don't yelling at you Martin
shkreli is more the kind of guy who he
knows how to provoke you yeah he knows
how to provoke you and laugh at you
anytime he's about to be proven wrong or
question on something he can just
provoke you even more it seems like
Trump still cares what you think whereas
yeah Martin shkreli is it's gonna kind
of take any opportunity to kind of poke
right back at you I think a big thing in
our society right now is like internet
trolling it's a very you know really
talked about thing I'm like I hear it
all the time I'm like TV or comics talk
about or whatever I feel like he is the
definition of that troll that we get to
see where as opposed to motion trolls
you don't know what they look like we
usually assume there's some fat dude
behind a computer this guy is like the
most public troll you'll ever see
now he takes to Twitter and picks fights
with people John was showing me how like
wu-tang clan had this likes a very
special album they only released one
album of it and then he bought it for a
[ __ ] ton of money and then he started
fighting with wu-tang
clan he even tried getting Kanye West's
album but the reason why he's kind of
scary too is because he is intelligent I
was watching this documentary about him
and he this guy has a wide set of skills
a wide variety of knowledge I would like
to see that more in terms of clearly as
high class interests he's the definition
of a guy who takes knowledge as power to
it to an evil extreme yeah it seems like
he I mean he does these sort of maniacal
things that seemingly for the fun of it
because he knows he's smarter than you
yeah yeah that's what makes him scary
cuz it's like it's kind of hard to fight
with him yeah exactly
because he kind of know that he knows
how to like counteract whether it
there's some base of logic or he'll know
you'll know how to get a rise out of you
instead well yeah and you know that no
matter how good your argument might be
he's not gonna let you win that would be
an interesting character study because
in a way American Psycho is a character
study and when I see this guy is more I
see this guy the more I wonder who are
you when you're just alone at home and
that's the kind of fascinating thing you
could explore with something I can make
American Psycho yeah it's it's like this
idea that you came up with is like if it
was like kind of like Martin shkreli and
you find out that when he's alone he's
also a serial killer you explore who is
and that's one facet of that that's
that's one of the bits that we don't see
and that's the fantasy of the movies is
that's how it would be a remake
basically as we touched on like you kind
of follow the basic plot structure you
kill somebody and then somebody the you
know the Willem Dafoe whoever we replace
Willem Dafoe with comes to investigate
it yeah and use that loose plotline and
then the rest is just you know a dark
mirror to modern narcissism and
materialism and I feel like it would be
cool to make it a little meta in terms
of like it would be funny if like in
casual passing like you see that he
phones a clip of American Psycho you get
like an actual celebrity in there to
play them cells moved like this Martin
shkreli type likes to antagonize it
seems like the guy would have seen
American Psycho and can tell you why he
thinks Patrick big like no not that he
would necessarily cop to thinking
Patrick Bateman's a good character but
be like yeah I I can tell you what I
admire about Patrick Bateman whereas
usually that's not where your
conversation would start and in terms of
the killing aspect of this we didn't
really discuss beforehand we wanted to
kind of brainstorm a little bit in from
camera we did this off-the-cuff we need
to discuss beforehand but I was I was
thinking in terms of him being a killer
I remember Patrick Bateman was more of
like he just got the job done pretty
fast
he takes an axe jared leto and he just
[ __ ] annihilates him well it seems
like he has these violent urges that
he's always keeping justjust yeah
waiting below it's like getting it's
like getting that orgasm man yeah like I
just got to come like that kind of
feeling about what killing that he kind
of has but he is a clean you know
methodical guy so that yeah that's how
it comes out I would like to see a guy
who's not as fast in terms of his
killing you know like one of the shows I
really loved that I've seen is Dexter I
think it'd be kind of neat to see a guy
who does take his time a little bit more
with his victims
one thing that was neat about American
Psycho zat whot sadistic and while it's
violent you don't really see much of
what happens he takes an accessary Leto
in the movie but you don't ever see
Jared Leto get hit with the axe
you know and the same thing with like a
woman who he drops a chainsaw on you
know you don't see that happen but you
can feel it I think it'd be cool to have
a little bit of a balance of times where
you don't see it and times where you
actually do see it cuz I feel like what
the violence we get nowadays they like
we can kind of get away with seeing a
little bit more of that blast we're not
going to go to destroy where the point
where the violence takes away from
psychological study of this character
there's an argument to be had about how
to approach the violence and a remake
like this and as I'm imagining it now I
almost feel like I would have it be
spare you know it wouldn't be like a
slasher movie but I would kind of want
another tone of Drive but you know how
like every time there's a violent moment
in Drive it's like whoa that's very real
like it feeling I'm real like that's
what I would want for this is like to
have that added psychological of what
real violence looks like especially now
that we have so many violent movies
there are more and more pg-13 action
movies that feel violent but without the
consequences like I would want to show
that violence real just so that it's
very jarring and I would like his status
to be higher in the public eye like I
imagine he's the kind of guy who would
probably study things like self-help
books or personal development stuff but
really manipulative
be doing like like pickup artistry stuff
yeah maybe that's why when we first
talked about this I said I imagine Tom
Cruise from Magnolia okay that study of
mentality of how people work and how to
really manipulate them you can either
totally recreate the Paul Allen seniors
with that whoo tang out yeah
do you like the Wu Tang and I don't
imagine him being a guy who's like super
physically strong like worse but we're
like Patrick Bateman was someone who was
very fit and very buff I would imagine
he's a healthy guy you know like he
seems like a regular lanky 30-something
with maybe like I can't go get a walks
around New York and shed and then yeah
yeah like I can't get a read not that I
you know like I don't know the guy I
don't know what his attention to health
would be and that's again that's another
sort of interesting thing to explore is
what would I imagine he takes care of
himself one thing I really liked about
it was seeing morning shkreli like in
terms of covering this subject was he
can get you to believe him sometimes yes
like a little bit when he's doing his
interviews and where he's like you know
some people make you have to be an evil
guy but the truth is I really do care
about people but then when he starts
talking you're like maybe he's done the
truth and I think I'd be cool in the
Moot in a movie to see kind of a
portrayal like that where you're you're
questioning is there good in this guy at
all
that's sort of in the tune of the
sociopath the psychopath that he is
because that's what I liked about
calling the film American Psycho
American Psycho was it is a study of a
psychopath and I would like to see an
even deeper psychological study of that
one who is today's psychopath then why
does he kill versus why did Patrick
Bateman kill you yeah yeah yeah cuz
those are the things that would make it
worthwhile really you you updated for
now well the Patrick Bateman's hailed we
we didn't really know why he killed or
why he killed the way he did cuz usually
when a serial killer becomes a serial
killer kind of a ritual that's a little
bit more specific as to why they kill a
certain way or why they choose their
victims to be these kind of people it
would be interesting to see specifically
learn a little bit about why he actually
does the killing I think it's just not a
lot I want to like too much on it but
just a little bit I feel like it's a
combination
like he keeps talking about it is in the
original movie about how him see how
he's not
there's nobody there you know I'm
talking about like up rings Oh
and like the trauma that's been
inflicted in him in his development that
has caused them to become a killer
there's an argument there because one
might say that'll take away a lot of the
fear and the mystery as to why he is
that person but then I at the same time
though I'm like I can't help but feel
that I would be a little interested just
to see why he does become that way I
wouldn't want to explain it per se but I
wouldn't want to subtly at least inject
like how am ia niak it makes it clear as
to why he kills and why he does the
killings the way he does but it doesn't
take away from why it's scary but it's
not like he has a victim and he's like
you know what happened to me when I was
younger it's not like telling his life
story to a victim you know what and and
yet and it maniac those those scenes
kind of serve to make it all the more
conflicting because you're like I feel
kind of sorry for this guy even though
he's terrible like you know yeah and and
I don't support him in any way and I
think it'd be quote they did honor the
weird tone oh yeah cuz I love that
American Psycho has a very kind of
surreal 'no cebause it this is seen
through the world of patrick because
you're in this guy's head yeah yeah yeah
all from this guy's perspective but
instead of seeing a normal world and
then we're focusing on this guy I think
it would be cool to see it from his
perspective see a like see the world how
he sees them and stuff and have the
style of the movie reflect that yeah you
know like that would give you a chance
to then have a your own style that's
more based on now and I just I really do
think that making it more of a public
figure would make him different already
and more introduced this Patra baby is
not a public figure in American Psycho
and I think it'd be cool to have a guy
who like does have like a Twitter
following and he's and his reputation is
like one of the most evil people in
America and stuff see he said to have
interviews where he's like I just don't
believe I'm evil he seems like the
perfect level of that kind of guy for me
right now because again people know who
he is but it's always just when he's
doing something like his own yeah and of
shitty thing it's not like he's an
actor's and they were he's everywhere
all the time it's just like you kind of
know who he isn't hear about him
sometimes and I feel like that's the
level of celebrity you could get away
yeah
like the only stuff we have of him him
losing his [ __ ] or Twitter rants yeah we
don't we don't have footage of him
losing his [ __ ] you know know what that
guy looks like when he's yeah we don't
like what he's like truly riled up like
we only have like tweets we don't have
like video of him like completely losing
it that's when I think it might be cool
intense in tune with kind of how Patrick
Bateman was because when Patrick Bateman
kills he tends to lose his [ __ ] yeah you
know and I had that might be the time
when he does lose his [ __ ] as opposed to
just being there we'll call him serial
killer there would be some [ __ ] losing
in this movie that is part of the
fascinating contrast is sort of like oh
my yeah this very calm like super
collected guys now being so vicious so
to sum it up well we wouldn't imagine
for an American Psycho reboot of how we
think you could work and this was our
first time attempting a video like this
so yeah the place it'll get shaped yeah
more of these well you basically imagine
is that it's a Martin shkreli yet like
type with similar themes but more
modern-day the exploration of his
lifestyle would be different who he is
would be different it would just be a
different kind of high power
money-hungry kind of guy yeah and you
know mm just a different movie with the
same themes you know yeah cuz that's all
they're doing is they're exploring the
sort of poster child for American
capitalism and I imagined him to be in
everybody I don't mean that in like a
homophobic way always I don't want to
upset anyone I know that America from
Patrick Bateman we you know that
explored his sex life and for some
reason this interpretation I imagine
that he would be homosexual and I don't
mean that in a way like gay people were
the killer I just don't want that to
come across sexual orientation I think
what I would do if I was running with
that is sort of like I would play with
toxic masculinity I guess at that point
this is where we're delving more into
the the purely fictional because I have
no idea what what is actual you know
love life is like but yeah it's like if
I was gonna do that I would make it so
that he can't confront those thoughts
and that's part of what contributes to
him yeah doing these horrible things and
in fact you could maybe have him get too
close to an encounter and kill somebody
because of that and then you have an
exploration of how you know that kind of
toxic masculinity in the way it forces
you to kind of crush yourself down
have horrible consequences and whatnot I
guess the last thing we would cover on
this is who we think could probably play
this guy I haven't been any phone into
this I just came up with a question
right now who a played a mortgage really
Sarah my god British to you to play an
American actor
that's a good question I'm gonna have to
think for a while and then I think yeah
I actually don't know who Jesse
Eisenberg as Lex Luthor for us yeah let
us know what you thought of this
American Psycho reboot idea or you know
put down your own idea of what you think
they should do I know some of you're
gonna be like just don't do it and yeah
that's how we essentially feel to do it
actually the more we talked about it the
more I think that this thing I think
this this show will probably have is by
the end of it do we still think it can
really at work you know and why they
remade carry and that bummed me out
because that was what I saw her I was
like you can totally update the themes
and tell a new version of that story and
have it be worth while an American
Psycho I can kind of see that now is it
necessary no but no [ __ ] film ever is
necessary Holzer guys yeah like I don't
really see the point because yeah what
new [ __ ] can you bring to this other
than like drones yeah but I think of the
American Psycho if it's an act if you're
if you're gonna remake Patrick Bateman
then there's no point yeah but if you're
gonna explore the themes of American
Psycho in a different character study
then I could see how it can be worth
someone's time till it then you bring
back Mila Kunis see ya and Williams [ __ ]
I think they just pick up for more
Americans I go to yeah there you go
let's continue with that there's you
across the room just brief some darker
stuff in there to just get all the
sequel's people don't like all right
guys we need a channel subscribe today
become a reject John is the social media
manager at facebook.com slash Blum house
and facebook.com slash the real rejects
I want to give a shout out to any signor
I don't care what people say about your
weight I think you're sexy [ __ ]
sexy guy is a sexy guy incredibly
charming seems sweet when we went on
Andres black endure comedy show on
screen junkies which of course I can't
remember the title the show right now
which is great for us we get to get make
a movie together
and he was like touching me and like
hugging me and II couldn't help but feel
very good about myself the way you
phrased that I would say it in the
courtroom